so willkommen zur heutigen sitzung heute
haben wir uns einen ganz neuen denker
vorgeknöpft
bevor ich ein bisschen näheres über ihn
sagen möchte ich noch mal hier auf den
und denker der letzten sitzung kurz
eingehen immanuel kant und dazu noch mal
dieses schaubild hier nochmal kurz
präsentieren ist ihm dieses bild so weit
klar können sie damit etwas anfangen
kann das von ihnen jemand noch mal kurz
erläutern wie wir jetzt hier kann es
dann zeit theorie bestimmt hatten
können sie das mal versuchen anhand
dieses schaubild ein bisschen zu
erklären freiwillige vorgehen möchte mal
wir können beginnt noch einmal mit ganz
innen was was ist es in der mitte was
was sind diese komischen sternchen da
wir haben wir das genannt was
symbolisieren diese kreuzchen diese
sternchen bitte genau das sind die
sinneseindrücke also haben sie ein
beispiel was wäre ein beispiel für ein
solches sternchen das so aufblitzt
ja genau also dass man sagt diese weiß
eindruck verbund mit dem schwarz
eindruck wenn ich jetzt sagen würde das
haben sie halt nicht gesagt aber wenn
sie jetzt sagen würden oder wie wäre
jemand sagen würde auf diese frage
beispiel für sinnes daten wenn man jetzt
sagen würde das pult dass ich da sehe
was wäre dann daran falsch nach kant bin
ich auf die frage was ist das da diese
kreuzchen antworten würde ein beispiel
und dann sagen würde ja zum beispiel das
pult das pult zeigt sich in form dieser
sternchen
das wäre dann falsch
ja genau ich glaube es geht in die
richtige richtung also wenn ich sage das
pult dann habe ich damit noch viel mehr
schon vorausgesetzt als nur sinnes daten
wie zum beispiel jetzt hier rot und hart
und ich weiß nicht was zum beispiel habe
ich damit vorausgesetzt schon mindestens
die reine anschauungs form des raumes
und den rhein verstandes begriff der
substanz dem ich sagen kann das pult
also deswegen muss man sagen wie sie es
getan haben zb ein rot eindruck zb der
eindruck einer härte ein bestimmter
geruch das jetzt bei kant nicht so
richtig interessant der geruch spielt
nicht so eine rolle und auch nicht so
eine große rolle spielt das akustische
bekannt aber das wären solche beispiele
für die materie wie kann sie nennt so
etwas was kommt jetzt als nächste
rahmung darum die reine an chance von
der zeit und was ist jetzt nach kant
eine form der sinnlichkeit hier habe ich
sind geschrieben die form persönlichkeit
was ist eine form der sinnlichkeit im
unterschied zu einem sinnes datum und zu
einer form des verstandes
wohin gehört jetzt die sinnlichkeit die
form der sinnlichkeit ist jetzt was
rationales gehörte zum verstand oder
gehört sie nicht eher zur materie der
sinnes daten was würden sie sagen oder
vielleicht sogar nichts von beiden
wie stellen sie sich so eine reine an
chance haben derzeit vor
das ist ja sagen die these bekannt was
hat es mit der aufsicht können sie die
noch ein bisschen genauer beschreiben
sie reine anschauungs form der zeit
oder des raumes
kennen sie noch an das beispiel wie kann
überhaupt auf diese reine form der
sinnlichkeit des raumes unter zeit
gestoßen ist erinnern sie sich daran
noch dieses text beispiel was wir daten
hatte kant gesagt ja genau
also wir können uns jetzt zum beispiel
dieses pult denken so dass wir davon
jetzt mal alles sinnes daten abziehen
also zum beispiel ist die röte weg die
härte weg vielleicht dicke hoch weg
riecht ein bisschen nach holz geruch weg
wenn ich ihn klopfe geruch ton weg als
akustisches signal weg man würde kann
sagen dann leiten bleiben noch zwei
dinge mindestens übrig dann bleibt noch
übrig die substanz des dinges dass es
auch in der philosophie bestritten
worden
es gibt zum beispiel thesen der
empirischen wie der irrtum die sagen
wenn ich alle sinneseindrücke von einem
möglichen gegenstand der erfahrung also
alle materie
wenn ich die aktie dann bleibt am ende
nichts mehr übrig das sagt david hume
also wenn ich alle gesundes qualitäten
alle perzeption aktie dann bleibt am
ende nichts mehr übrig ich jung sagt ein
objekt ist nur ein bündel von
konzeptionen kann sagt nein ganz und gar
nicht sondern wenn ich alle sinne daten
weg zieht dann bleibt er ist noch übrig
die substanz also nicht jetzt die
konkrete substanz durch anfassen kann
sondern die tatsache dass der pult dass
das pult eine substanz ist also dass es
sich hierbei um etwas handeln dem ich
bestimmte eigenschaften zu sprechen kann
das ist das erste also ich schreibe es
mal hin
damit das pult pult und jetzt mache ich
hier
- ich mache das jetzt als negation ist
vielleicht nicht ganz richtig - sinnes
daten - substantially tät schreibe jetzt
mal substantially tät
also wenn ich die sind es daten aktie
ist damit die substanzielle verfasstheit
dieses bildes noch nicht berührt das ist
ganz interessant
und jetzt sagt kant wenn ich jetzt aber
auch noch die substantially tät wegnehme
dann bleibt noch übrig was bleibt da
noch übrig vom pult oder was bleibt
überhaupt noch übrig
bleibt noch übrig die form der der
sinnlichkeit als dann bleibt noch übrig
irgendwas zeitlich räumlich ausgedientes
zeitlich räumlich ausgedehnte als ist
das war der punkt wenn wir die substanz
wegnehmen dann ist damit noch nicht
gemeint dass wir auch das räumliche
zeitliche wegnehmen und daraus folgt
diese
grafik hier dass wir hier eine
unabhängigkeit haben von sinnes daten
von der raub der form der zeit und des
raumes und von der form dem verständnis
begriff der substanz also substanz
müssen wir uns bekannt er logisch
vorstellen wie in einem urteil das
subjekt eine stille bezieht ein subjekt
dem können verschiedene prädikat
zugeschrieben werden zum beispiel das
pult ist rot dann wäre eben das pult er
die substanz als die subjekt stelle im
urteil oder im satz also substanz darf
man sich jetzt nicht vorstellen als das
was da ausgedehnt ist sonst substanz ist
einfach nur die logische funktion die
dafür notwendig ist dass wir davon
sprechen können dass ein bestimmtes nie
gestand gegenstand ein bestimmter
gegenstand ist und dass dieser
gegenstand als solcher bestimmte
eigenschaften hat also formen traumzeit
und jetzt speziell die zeit ist eine
form der sinnlichkeit und damit kommt
ihr ein ganz eigentümliche status zu
nämlich sie ist so eine art mittelding
ein mittelding zwischen der es den zins
daten
das hat was mit erfahrung zu tun und den
rhein verstandes begriffen also die form
der sinnlichkeit er eine von der
sinnlichkeit ist ein zwischending ebenso
wie der raum ein zwischending zwischen
der materie zwischen dem sinnes daten
und zwischen den verstand es begriffen
als ganz seltsames ding und kann zeigt
eben in köln eben logisch von dem pult
für den konkreten gegenstand dieses
daten weg den die substantia lied
mitdenken auch noch anderes einheit viel
halt usw
die ganzen verstandes kathrin und dann
bleibt übrig das sie noch zeitlich und
räumlich ausgelegt dass da noch was
zeitlich räumlich ausgedehnte es ist
hier stellt sich natürlich die frage
inwiefern dies noch individuen werden
kann dass ausgedehnt das scheint dann
doch mit den verstandes begriffen wieder
zusammen zu hängen aber man kann zeigen
dass sich diese ganzen eigenschaften
unabhängig voneinander verhalten und
analysieren lassen
ja und das ist jetzt sozusagen diese
these von kant sehr wirksam also man
kann sich jetzt vor allem welchen status
hat die zeit sie ist nach kant eben das
durchaus subjektiv aber indem sie
subjektiv ist ist sie wieder macht es
überhaupt objektivität möglich also man
darf jetzt kanntest theorie nicht so
denken dass bei kant alles subjektiv ist
weil wir hier noch dieses
transzendentale ich um alles herum
gerannt ist sondern denkt sich dass er
so es ist nicht so dass ich
subjektivität und objektivität gegenüber
stehen in der welt dass ihr das
objektive gibt und hier gibt es das
subjektive das ist ja häufig so eine
vorstellung haben das subjektive und das
subjekt und hier haben wir das objektive
oder das objekt und es ist nicht so dass
ich das subjekt auf das ob die gerichtet
und es erkennen muss das ist häufig
stellt man sich das vorher also hier
gibt es eine canon das subjekt und das
erkennen des optik muster zu erkennen
denn objekt sich möglichst gut annähern
und wenn es sich dem objekt angenähert
hat dann erkennt dass das objekt genau
so kann man sich auch wahrheit
vorstellen wahrheit ist die
übereinstimmung von subjektivität der
meinung der erkenntnis und objektivität
und jetzt sagt nein das ist falsch
ein falsches modell sondern wir dürfen
uns objektivität müssen uns objektivität
so vorstellen dass objektivität nur
durch subjektivität möglich ist wir
müssen den pfeil hier zurück machen
wir bekommen nicht objektivität frei
haus so dass die objektivität einfach so
vorliegt sondern die objektivität ist
eine funktion der subjektivität
das ist die pointe bekannt als alles das
was objektivität ausmacht zum beispiel
dass es räumlich und zeitlich ist das
ist substanziell verfasst ist dass es
individuell ist dass es eben ein
gegenstand ist der erkennbar ist das
verdankt der gegenstand geben den formen
unseres verstandes und informel unserer
sinnlichkeit also objektivität wird
durch subjektivität gerade konstruiert
oder konstituiert und nicht irgendwie
objektivität steht der subjektivität
immer schon gegenüber
das ist sagen geplante und in diesem
gefüge von erkenntnistheoretischen
bedienungs verhältnissen in diesem
gefüge kommt der form der sinnlichkeit
der reinen form der sinnlichkeit eben
eine wichtige rolle zu
die sind praktisch die rahmenbedingungen
innerhalb deren erster erkenntnis
möglich ist konkret erkennt es möglich
ist ich hatte jetzt mir lange überlegt
soll ich jetzt hier die form der
sinnlichkeit als rahmen überall so
praktisch über den rahmen des verstandes
ziehen der substanz aber nicht gemacht
und zwar deswegen weil eben die zwischen
stellung dadurch besser betont wird
zwischen materie und verstand aber
vielleicht sollte man sie sich
eigentlich als nochmal die substanz
übergreifend denken dass tan zentrale
ist jedenfalls der letzte bezugsrahmen
diesem diesem diesem gefüge das noch mal
kurz als wiederholungen haben sie noch
fragen zu dieser theorie ja
[Musik]
ja genau das war ja ihre frage mal zb
die dinosaurier und sieht dinosaurier
wesen und so die hatten doch gar kein
trans zentrales ich da ist es dann so
dass kant mit der software stellt wenn
subjektivität auftritt und ich glaube
verkannt ist es notwendig dass
subjektivität irgendwann mal aufgetreten
ist es entspannte frage ist überhaupt
eine welt vorstellbar ohne mögliche
subjekte es ent spannende frage diese
frage werden wir uns am ende in unserem
seminar stellen wenn wir auf anton
friedrich koch diesen modernen
philosophen eingehen der behauptet dass
nämlich das eine welt ohne blick gar
nicht möglich ist
aber wir haben jetzt einfach mal die
tatsache dass wir uns subjekt haben zum
beispiel wir jetzt ja und dann denkt
sich das kann so dass wir eben in
unserer ein anschauungs vom derzeit auch
die ganze vergangenheit mit konstruieren
also wir die reine anschauungs form gilt
dann nicht nur für die gegenwart sind
eben auch für die vergangenheit wir
rekonstruieren die vergangenheit der
dinosaurier auch in unseren reihen
anschluss form der zeit
es gab es ein bisschen paradox ist aber
so wir mit unserer unserer reihen an
chance haben derzeit wir sind sagen auch
die bedingung dafür dass in diesen
zeiten wo dinosaurier lebt zeit war das
geht natürlich nur dann wenn es
überhaupt subjektivität gibt wenn es
keine subjektivität gibt dann ist die
frage wirklich zentral ob es dann
überhaupt zeit gibt stellen sich eine
welt vor ohne erkenntnis objekte nur mit
fels sowie eine marslandschaft ohne
außerirdische intelligenzen universum
nur mit planeten und sternen
ohne ecke ohne subjekte die erkennen
können existiert amtseid und kant würde
sagen nein
dann existiert keine zeit
das würde kann sagen
das heißt er ist insofern ist und wie
zeit geht ein transzendentaler idealist
brands and a bedeutet dass sich hierbei
um eine rahmung handelt alles was trans
zentral ist müssen sie sich in form
dieser rahmen vorstellen mit günstigen
dieser sternchen der sternchen die sind
sein realistisches ein realistischer
teil sagt die werbung zeige gebe von
außen die haben die produzieren wir
nicht wir können nicht darüber verfügen
ob die türe jetzt die wand jetzt weiß
oder rot ich kann jetzt nicht wollen
dass die wand rot ist einer wird sie rot
das geht nicht dass diese sind es daten
müssen wir gegeben sein
aber alles andere alle rahmungen hier
das natürlich auch nicht unseren willen
jetzt verfügbar aber die hängen mit
unserer subjektivität sang alles was in
diesem rahmen sich hier was diese
rahmenstruktur hat spricht diese sterne
struktur das kann man transzendentalen
und trans zentral mein team gerade das
dass das objektive durch das subjektive
erst ein spiel kann also objektivität
als funktion der subjektivität als auf
ihre frage wir würden uns dann die zeit
eben konstruieren also nicht jetzt dass
wir uns die dinosaurier konstruiert ab
insofern wir jetzt als erkenntnis
objekte die reine anfangs von der zeit
haben können wir in der zeit zurückgehen
in der rhein an chance form zurück
millionen jahre zurückliegen es hängt an
unserer subjektivität und das ist
sicherlich in einer gewissen hinsicht
paradox oder bisschen problematisch
also die zeit bekommt eben wird ganz
stark abhängig vom subjekt und man würde
doch sagen eine welt in der keine
subjekte existieren
der existiert auch die zeit oder stimmen
wir mal ab wer von ihnen ist der meinung
dass in einer welt in einem universum wo
keine subjekte existieren können niemals
existiert das da dennoch zeit existiert
mit dem anmelden
die erste meinung dass es nicht ist ja
also ich will es gar nicht bewerten also
es gibt eben dct zb mein chef herr
buchan buchheim sagt dass eben die zeit
nicht vom subjekte erkenntnis abhängig
ist professor buchhandlung ist ein
transzendentaler realist er sagt diese
ganzen rahmungen hier die existieren
unabhängig von unserer erkenntnis
subjektivität anton friedrich kocht der
besagte heidelberger philosoph der sagt
nein ein universum ohne subjekte ist gar
nicht denkbar ist muss subjektivität
geben also anders gesagt nur wenn wir
subjektivität haben haben wir zeit das
sind einfach zwei positionen der
gegenwärtigen debatte vielleicht gibt es
noch eine dritte weiß ich jetzt nicht
vielleicht gibt es eine dritte die dann
diese probleme lösen kann aber es ist
immer so ein bisschen der streit
zwischen idealismus und realismus
derzeit aber erkannt eben nicht jetzt
subjektivismus also kannst theorie der
reinform der sinnlichkeit bedeutet nicht
dass zeit was subjektives ist im 10
jedes relativen bei einstein also gerade
nicht diese relativität bei 1 stand das
jetzt wie einen bewegten system die zeit
langsamer verläuft und so sondern es ist
einfach so dass nur durch subjektivität
überhaupt zeit möglich ist und dass die
zeit ein möglich ist oder wenn sie
möglich ist das bedeutet dann dass wir
das newtonsche bild wieder haben also
absolute seit die zeit verrinnt
gleichmäßig aber eben nur dank der
subjektivität die sie konstituiert das
ist jetzt so in aller kürze nochmal die
kantige theorie und jetzt kommen wir zu
einem anderen denker sie erkennen ihn
alle da bin ich mir ganz sicher wenn ich
ihnen jetzt gleich hier von ihm ein bild
zeige
wir machen nämlich jetzt wieder so eine
zeitreise und zwar den hier kennen sie
den
da waren vielleicht so 16 oder 18
sie kennen ihn noch nicht dann kennen
sie ihn vielleicht jetzt der wahre in
münchen und hat hier glaube ich ein
orden bekommen maximilian zu haben kennt
sie ihn jetzt
jetzt zeige ich ihnen noch ein bild und
jetzt kommt jeweils ganz besonders hier
zeige ich ihnen ihn gleich auch mit dem
namen und zwar mit einer der gero tipi
mit einer vorform der fotografie so sah
friedrich wilhelm josef schilling aus
das bild ist 1848 aufgenommen worden
ja das ist also eine vorform der
fotografie so hat der wirklich aus im
hohen alter
diese friedrich wilhelm joseph schelle
dadurch seine hand bewegt sehen sie hier
die es ein bisschen verschwommen bekommt
die hat er wahrscheinlich still gehalten
aber sonst ist das eine sehr gut
erhaltene fotografien und wir lesen
jetzt hier auszüge aus seiner schrift
die wild alter und die wild alter sind
ein sehr sehr dunkler text wie sie
wahrscheinlich schon selbst feststellen
mussten als sie sich die textauszüge
angesehen habe ich habe es versucht ich
jetzt ein bisschen zu erleichtern
sie finden die folien wenn sie die jetzt
parallel lesen wollen
sie finden die auf die lowcost oder in
der app unter dieser rubrik folien da
habe ich die neuesten folien
draufgeschrieben aufgeladen also sie
finden die seit gestern können sie die
auf dieser film cast app oder innenseite
sich noch zugleich jetzt hier
runterladen also die welt alter ein sehr
sehr schwieriges werk wie alt war der
gute mann da gar nicht so alt also sie
geschrieben hatten 36 das ist alles noch
sehr überschaubar aber es ist dennoch
sehr dunkel und sehr fragment hafte hat
es also auch gar nicht zu ende
geschrieben
es gibt da nur dieses buch erste kapitel
die facc
so heißt diese dieses erste kapitel und
wir lesen uns jetzt dass durch bevor wir
das machen werden wir aber noch ein paar
leitfragen hier uns anschauen als erster
welche bedeutung hat verschenkt die a3
derzeit also das ist praktisch diese
reihe wo subjekt gegenwart vergangenheit
und zukunft eine rolle spielen dann kann
man sich fragen welche rolle die drei
derzeit spielt das ist eine spannende
frage
meine these ist ja dass das bei
schelling jetzt hier eine ein wandel
stattfindet von von einer betrachtung
der bloßen frei kriegen zur arbeit das
ist also meine thesen die wollen wir
noch ein bisschen genauer versuchen die
versteht stellen die dimension der
vergangenheit in der geschichte wie
verhält sich schellings zeitbegriff zu
den bisher diskutierten insbesondere zu
demjenigen immanuel kants das ist als
jetzt die spannende frage
ok dann lesen einfach mal hier los also
er sagt von jeher hat philosophie die
grenzen der welt und damit der
gegenwärtigen zeit schreiten die erste
herkunft der dinge zu erklären gesucht
und sich so an die vergangenheit im
höchsten szene gewendet warum war oder
ist es bis jetzt unmöglich dass sie dem
wort und der sache nach historie ist
auch der form ist das bewusste wird
erzählt warum kann nicht auch das
bewusste der höchsten wissenschaft mit
gerat haid und einfalt wie jedes andere
gewusst erzählt werden was hält sie
zurück die ahndete goldene zeit da die
fabel wieder zu weit und die wahl zur
farbe wird gehen jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen schneller durch wie den
einfach heute ein paar sachen
präsentieren wir müssen das jetzt nicht
im detail analysieren also ich versuche
ihnen einfach mal ein bisschen nach
unterstützende hilfestellung zu geben
also für schelling wird jetzt plötzlich
eben die geschichte insofern die zeit
insofern zentral als es nicht mehr hier
nur um die bloße abfolge von ereignissen
geht als was war davor was war danach
usw
sondern für ihn bekommt die zeit so eine
qualitative bedeutung also tisch die a3
wird ganz ganz wichtig die arbeit wird
ganz ganz wichtig und die a 3 ist jetzt
die zeit reif die zeit unter dem
gesichtspunkt der vergangenheit der
gegenwart und der zukunft
und jetzt will er eben hier also ein
bisschen auch der form nach das
vergangene behandeln also er will
sozusagen eine weise finden wie man über
die vergangenheit adäquat reden kann wie
man adäquat über die vergangenheit reden
kann das ist jetzt die spannende also
nicht nur hier so der sache nach sollen
auch der form nach wie muss eine
philosophie aussehen die eine
philosophie der vergangenheit ist dass
es also jetzt wird die zentrale sagte
hier vergangenheit ein hoher begriff
allen gemein und nur wenige verstanden
die meisten wissen von keiner als der
welches sich in jedem augenblick durch
ebendiesen vergrößert selbst noch wird
nicht ist ohne bestimmte entschiedene
gegenwart gibt es keine wie viele
erfreuen sich eines solchen der mensch
der sich nicht scheiden kann von sich
selbst sich lossagen von allem was ihn
geworden und ihm sich tätig
entgegensetzten hat keine vergangenheit
oder filme kommt nie aus ihr heraus lebt
beständig in ihr wohl tätig und
förderlich ist der menschen das
bewusstsein etwas wie man sagt hinter
sich gebracht das heißt als
vergangenheit gesetzt zu haben
weiter wird ihm nur dadurch die zukunft
und leicht nur unter dieser bedingung
auch etwas vorsicht zu bringen
nur der mensch der die kraft hat sich
über sich selbst zu erheben ist fähig
eine wahre vergangenheit zu erschaffen
eben dieser genießt auch allein einer
wahren gegenwart wie allein
da eigentlich in zukunft entgegensieht
und schon aus diesen betrachtungen würde
hervor leuchten dass der gegensatz zu
zeiten auf einer steigerung beruht nicht
aber durch ein stetiges verfließen
derzeit teile ineinander hervorgebracht
wird dieses zitat halte ich für sehr
wichtig wie kann man sich jetzt das
vorstellen
also er sagt es die meisten dass jetzt
die abgrenzung der zweiten zeile die
meisten menschen wissen von keiner
vergangenheit als derjenigen
vergangenheit die sie in jedem auch
nicht durch ebendiesen vergrößert selbst
noch wird nicht ist also die
vergangenheit die wird immer größer weil
immer wieder von der zukunft die
gegenwart etwas in die vergangenheit
übergeht
sie wird immer größer wie so ein vieh
solle wie so eine sanduhr
ja sie haben hier ich glaube das ist ein
gutes beispiel
sie haben hier am zukunft das hier ist
die gegenwart und das jetzt die
vergangenheit und jetzt tröpfelt das
hier wird das hier unter fries und
herunter und dieses muntere gefäß wird
immer mehr an gefüllt so kann man sich
jetzt die vergangenheit vorstellen der
gab es eine meldung wert sich gemeldet
haben sie dann beleg am text oder kommen
wir noch vielleicht darauf im anderen
text also ich gebe ihnen insofern recht
dass bei schelling dieses normale gefüge
derzeit in ein neues verhältnis gebracht
wird ja das ist klar
als er sieht das ganz anders aber das
wäre jetzt mal das modell wie sich wie
man sich gemeinhin vorstellt
es tröpfelt einfach so weiter
okay das ist jetzt ein modell die
vergangenheit wird immer größer wieso
ein gefäß und dass die zukunft hinein
fließen
die zukunft wird natürlich auch nicht
kleiner ist klar also das ist nicht so
dass hier dieser pegel hier sinkt und
das wird auch ständig aufgefüllt die
zukunft ist sondern unendlich großes
reservoir natürlich die vergangenheit
auch das geht natürlich auch wissen es
unendlich unter das ist klar aber es
vergrößert sich jedenfalls
und bezogen auf eine existenz auf
individuelles wesen ist es tatsächlich
so dass die zukunft natürlich beschränkt
ist man hat eine gewisse lebenserwartung
und von dieser lebenserwartung tröpfelt
eben immer wieder sandkorn weise die
zeit in das gefäß der vergangenheit und
irgendwann zimmer daneben haben und das
ende erreicht
da ist die sanduhr sondern abgelaufen
und das das vergangenheit gefäß ist
voller sand
also kann man sich das durchaus
vorstellen aber das sagte janning das
ist falsch
ohne bestimmte entschieden gegenwart
gibt es keine
der mensch der sich nicht scheiden kann
von sich selbst sich lossagen von allem
was ihm geworden und ihm sicht
entgegensetzen hat keine vergangenheit
oder vielmehr kommt nie aus ihr heraus
die beständig in ihr wie verstehen sie
das
haben sie eine idee wie verstehen sie
das ist offensichtlich der mensch der
eben nur im hier und jetzt lebt der eben
nicht sich gedanken gemacht hatte der
eben nicht reflektiert der auch nicht
frei ist ne scheiben kann von sich
selbst das ist das hilft muss sein als
sich zu sich selbst verhalten jetzt ja
als das ist sicherlich ein beispiel ein
richtiges beispiel für das wasser sagt
ja aber es muss jetzt nicht nur das
bedeuten also es ein gutes beispiel dass
man sich eben zu seiner vergangenheit
und seiner gegenwart
hier geht's auf einen die gegenwart
verhältnis
[Musik]
zurück
ja also ich denke sie haben beide recht
also es geht darum dass man ein
selbstreflexive verhältnis hat sich zur
zeit in ein verhältnis setzt und von
derzeit nicht gefangen ist und zu sagen
schelling wird dann nämlich sagen dass
es eine form der mechanische zeit
auffassung gibt und das ist dann die
reihe
das ist dann einfach nur hier früher
oder später einfach dieses mechanische
modell was wir bei den usern gesehen
haben was wir auch bei kant gesehen
haben diese modelle gibt es auch aber
jetzt wollen wir mal weiter sagen also
wohl tätig und völlig ist den menschen
das bewusstsein etwas wie man sagt
hinter sich gebracht das heißt als
vergangenes gesetzt zu haben
das heißt man wird nicht vergangenheit
die zeit rinnt nicht durch ein hindurch
passiv sondern ein aktives modell wir
setzen die gegenwart in die
vergangenheit es ist unsere
vergangenheit sprich wir machen
geschichte
das ist die these von schelling
also wir setzen die vergangenheit wir
setzen wir bestimmen was vergangenheit
wird so lese ich dass wir falls
heute wird ihm nur dadurch die zukunft
und leicht nur unter dieser bedingung
auch etwas vor sich zu bringen
also es geht einmal an bringt einmal was
hinter sich hinter sich gebracht sehen
sie hier
hinter sich bringen und hier geht es um
das fonds sich bringt also die zeit die
gegenwart und die vergangenheit wird
jetzt im sinne der arai gedacht also das
überhaupt vergangenheit in zukunft die
rolle spielt zeigt dass sich hier um die
a3 handelt jetzt haben wir die gegenwart
das heißt es geht hier wir setzen die
zukunft und wir setzen die vergangenheit
das heißt hier einmal hinter sich
bringen und einmal vor sich bringen
sie haben sich gemeldet
biologisches mittel
richtig sie haben völlig recht das ist
eine gute psychologische illustration
dessen was schelling natürlich dann noch
sehr metaphysisch setzt also sie bringen
es ein gutes beispiel dass das belegt
aber schelling wir natürlich sagen hier
geht es nicht nur um psychologie die
psychologie ist kann das
veranschaulichen wie geht es um eine
grundstruktur wie wir überhaupt in der
welt existieren aber völlig richtig
natürlich so kann man sich das erklären
wir müssen uns zur zukunft und zur
vergangenheit verhalten die
vergangenheit darf uns nicht belasten
wie so ein gewicht was am bein dass wir
in bayern mitschleppen sind wir müssen
über unsere vergangenheit selbst
entscheiden
und genauso wie der zukunft die zukunft
darf nichts drohen das sein was uns auf
uns zu stürzen wir müssen in freiheit
die zukunft selbst gestalten und wie
können wir die zukunft selbst gestalten
haben sie eine idee wie könnten wir
jetzt zum beispiel die zukunft zu
modifizieren dass sie uns nicht mehr als
etwas fremdes vielleicht auch
gefährliches gegenübersteht haben sie
die wie kann man das machen jetzt
mehrere möglichkeiten
wir können bis zwölf so machen indem wir
die zukunft planen indem wir also
projekte entwickeln uns etwas vor
sitzen vor sich bringen indem wir ziele
haben ziele die wir erreichen wollen
nachdem wir streben oder aber wir
könnten versuchen und das ist jetzt ganz
heilige risch so sieht das nämlich
heiliger wir könnten versuchen die
vergangenheit mit der zukunft in einen
bezug zu bringen dass wir sagen wir
wollen sagen aus der vergangenheit
letztendlich etwas lernen für die
zukunft die vergangenheit soll uns als
ein vorbild für die zukunft dienen wenn
wir das jedenfalls vergangenheit mit
zukunft märz anderen beschließen das
hatten sie sich gemeldet sind
mehr ist als bei den frauen
zwar richtig genau das ist es als sie
kommt der begriff der technologie ins
spiel geht hier um ziele und zwecke
ich muss die zeit sinnvoll das heißt
nach zielen und rücken strukturieren und
nicht nur eben mich an das ist jetzt für
schelling immer so ein gegenmodell
dieses mechanische verständnis der zeit
und schelling setzt kant gleich mit
diesem mechanischen zeitbild das darauf
möchte ich sie hinweisen und jetzt
möchte sie noch was anderes hinweisen
nämlich auf die these dass der gegensatz
der zeiten auf einer steigerung beruht
nicht aber durch ein stetiges verfließen
derzeit teile ineinander hervorgebracht
dass der zins verstehen bestimmt ja
ja genau genau als er ist die gegensätze
zeit auf einer steigerung beruht das
heißt dass er nicht durch ein stetiges
verfließen derzeit teile ineinander
dafür gebracht wird
der gegensatz zu zeigen das ist
wahrscheinlich vergangenheit und zukunft
dass die gegensatz der wird nicht durch
einfließen dieses sanduhr modell das das
sandkörnchen einmal hier ist und einmal
hier ist es wäre jetzt es sanduhr modell
so dürfen wir uns jetzt vergangenheit
und zukunft nicht vorstellen sondern
dass es eine steigerung ist und jetzt
ist die frage wie soll man sich jetzt
die steigerung vorstellen was wird jetzt
gesteigert wird jetzt die zukunft zur
vergangenheit gesteigert oder die
vergangenheit zur zukunft gesteigert wie
würden sie diese zahl
welche richtung würde ich sagen ich
glaube es muss er zukunft gesteigert
sein dass wir also uns eben von der
vergangenheit seien nach vorne
entwickeln so ein entwicklungs mutter so
da ist wieder die tränen die sie genannt
hatten als wir streben auf etwas zu wir
haben bestimmte stadien erreicht und wir
steigern und sie wollen immer
weiterkommen dahin steht natürlich auch
ein sehr stark freiheits theoretisches
modell im hintergrund gibt es dagegen
kritische einwände
das wäre jetzt alte das hinter sich
bringen genau
mensch sagt jawohl tätig und förderlich
ist dem menschen das bewusstsein etwas
wie man sagt hinter sich zu bringen
das ist wohl tätig und jetzt heiter also
sie haben richtig ist da durchaus noch
eine gewichtung drin also es ist wohl
tätig und heiter wird sie nur wenn man
auch etwas vor sich bringt also man muss
offensichtlich ist die frage wie genau
die gestaltung der zukunft aussehen zu
aber ich stelle es mir so vor dass wir
uns pläne schmieden dass wir die zukunft
schon verplanen und dass wir in die
zukunft hinein denken unsere freiheit
als im sinne auch der möglichkeiten ich
habe jetzt diese möglichkeit könnte das
machen dass das also mit möglichen
welten zu bringen mit alternativen dass
dieses operieren mit alternativen in der
freiheit so stell ich mir das vor sich
bringen
vor vielleicht haben sie ja noch bessere
ideen wie man sich das vor sich bringen
vorstellen kann
die zukunft wird damit eben nicht so
etwas was nur auf mich zukommt sondern
die zukunft wird vorgebracht die zukunft
läuft nicht auf mich zu ist nicht
objektiv ist so ich laufe in der zukunft
vor
das ist der punkt die zukunft kommt
nicht vor
und jetzt sind wir gleich bei heiliger
bei heutiger spricht vom vor laufen
halten sagt dann dass halver heiliger
spielt dann immer der tod große rolle
heiliger spricht vom vorlaufen zum tod
also verteidiger ist das letzte ziel der
tod
und wenn dann spielt man vom vorlaufen
auf die tot
natürlich stark existenz philosophisch
jetzt gedacht
aber ich hatte so eine struktur von
vorlaufen es ist vorsicht bringen
das natürlich einen vorlauf aber hier
klingt schon heilige an oder heilige hat
sich jetzt sehr auf schilling bezogen
es geht darum dass die zukunft nicht als
etwas uns um verfügbares gedacht wird
was einfach da auf uns zukommen sondern
wir gestalten die zukunft mit wir
bestimmen was da auf uns zukommt und das
kam mir ganz einfach tun indem ich eben
etwas plane in freiheit dass ich sage so
in einem jahr möchte ich das gemacht
haben in einem jahr soll folgendes
vergangenheit geworden geworden sein
überlegen sie gleich überlegen sich mal
wenn sie jetzt ein neujahrsvorsatz sich
vor hilfen ist ja bald wieder von anlass
gegeben
sagen sie was möchte ich im nächsten
jahr alles erreicht möchte das machen
dass das das möchten sie dass etwas auf
sie zukommt was sie selbst schon mehr
oder weniger projektiert haben sie
machen ein projekt da kommt nichts auf
sie zu was für sie fremd ist sondern
kommen sie sich selbst entgegen der
zukunft nämlich durch ihre projekte
sagen am soundsovielten möchte ich eine
tagung machen
im juni 29 juni möchte ich eine tagung
organisieren zum thema was ist
digitalität mache ich jetzt folgen ist
dann versuche ich jetzt schon die raum
den raum dafür zu bekommen auch wenn es
schwierig ist hier an der lmu versuchen
alle mittel in bewegung zu setzen damit
dann eben irgendwann mal etwas
bestimmtes vergangenheit geworden ist
seit ich bestimmt eben das was sein wird
und auch das was mal vergangenheit
gewesen sein aber sie hat eine kritische
eintrete
das zwei tages sehen man kann nicht nur
welche aufstellen
etwas tun so leider noch nicht man muss
ihm das wirklich abschließend ist da was
kindern vergangen hat beschlossen dass
mancher denken dass bürger nicht nur den
so richtig als abgeschlossen wird das
ganze dadurch dass ist hinter sich
gebracht wird
hinter sich gebracht wird aber es hängt
natürlich insofern mit einer zusammen
als beide in dem subjekt in dem
existierenden individuum ihre wurzeln
haben und die zeit nicht nur so
durchläuft durch mich steigerung finde
ich auch noch wichtig hier als
einsteiger
eine steigerung muss ja also steiger es
wäre eine steigung also wir können sagen
eine steigung wäre treppenstufen eine
steigerung ja wie stellen sich das vor
eine steigerung da ist also eine
verbesserung
gut also eine verbesserung wird
irgendwas noch intensiviert es wird
immer weiter aufgebaut
gut er kann das mit diesen treppenstufen
vorstellen also es ist es gibt auch eine
gewisse normativität in der zeit also
die zukunft wird vielleicht sogar besser
mal was in der zukunft ist ist noch
nicht aber es wird noch besser könnte
man sich überlegen wie diese steigerung
hier stand wird jedenfalls wird zeit
hier plötzlich qualitativ gesetzt wenn
ich von einer steigerung sprechen dann
ist etwas irgendwie mehr besser schöner
wie auch immer als in der vergangenheit
ist ein qualitativer zeitbegriff ins
spiel kommt geht's einfach mal so ein
bisschen durch es gibt sehr viele
interessante zitat ich kann natürlich
jetzt nicht alle hier
ich habe eine auswahl wie könnte ich die
auch wie gesagt auf den folien jetzt
schon anschauen auf die lowcost wäre die
welt eine wie einige vermeinte weise
behauptet eine rück und vorwärts ins
endlose laufende kette von ursachen und
wirkungen zu gebe es im waren verstanden
so wenig eine vergangenheit als eine
zukunft aber dieser ungedanken sollte
mit dem mechanischen system dem an einer
angehört belegt zugleich verschwunden
sagen das ist jetzt eine ganz klare zu
verstehen jedenfalls eine ganz klare
absage an die bh derzeit ne natürlich
auch an ganz theorie ist einfach nur
hier läuft irgendwas durch gibt es mir
ursache wirkung ursache wirkung hängt
natürlich wieder mit dem griff der
kausalität zu tun und sie haben zusammen
und sie habe natürlich ganz ruhig darauf
hingewiesen dass die technologie wichtig
wird also eine theologin theologisches
bestehen ist wo ich mir zwei gesetzte
ziele in die zukunft projizieren die
zukunft danach lebe nach einem ziel was
erfüllt werden soll
das ist natürlich kein mechanisches
verständnis von zeit ist ein
theologisches und kann wird auch an
einer anderen stelle sagen dass es ihm
um ein organismus geht als organist
tisches
systeme die organische auffassung von
zeit und nicht eine mechanische zeit das
gehört auch noch mit dazu
also hier ist auch noch ganz wichtig als
abgrenzung von der b 3 und die a 3 wird
verschenkt nach schell ich natürlich
noch sehr weiter aufgewertet und
modifiziert wäre jetzt gibt es hier noch
ein zitat das ist nochmal hier wichtig
und das möchte mal vorlesen wäre jedoch
auch in jedem sinne bewährt die alte
rede das nichts neues in der welt
geschehe wäre auf die frage was ist das
geschehen ist noch immer jede jene
antwort die richtige eben das was her
nach geschehen wird und auf die was ist
das geschehen wird eben das was zuvor
geschehen ist so würde daraus nur folgen
das die welt in sich keine
vergangenheiten keine zukunft habe das
alles was in ihr von anfang geschehen
ist und was bis zum ende geschehen wird
nur zu einer großen zeit gehört dass die
eigentliche vergangenheit vergangenheit
schlechthin die vorbildliche ist die
eigentliche zukunft die zukunft
schlechthin die nach weltliche und so
würde sich uns ein system der zeiten
entfalten von welchem das dem
menschlichen nur ein nach gilt eine
wiederholung in engeren kreis wäre
ich verstehe das
er spricht jetzt interessanter weise von
der eigentlichen vergangenheit und er
spricht von der eigentlichen zukunft
also in der wirklichen zukunft
und das möchte abgrenzen von bloßen
auffassung des vorher und das nachher
kann also auf die frage was geschehen
ist
einfach sagen was danach geschehen ist
das wäre einfach nur so ein
also praktisch das wäre nur so eine wer
ein betrachtung also auf die frage was
was geschehen ist was zuvor geschehen
ist wenn ich frage was ist geschehen war
das was zuvor geschehen ist dieser
zeitpunkt sommer t1 und was danach sogar
zu null
das ist t1 und die frage was geschehen
wird
was an
also jetzt ein bisschen schwierig wie
verstehen sie dass das wäre also immer
tc2 das war es an das was geschehen wird
das könnte man jetzt vielleicht zu
verstehen dass es einfach davor war in
diesem sinne
in diesem sinne dass es eben hier hier
davor liegt also davor denkt man jetzt
eigentlich ist in der vergangenheit
davor wenn ich sage davor etwas war vor
einer anderen sache deswegen hat mich
dieses gerade ein bisschen durcheinander
gebracht
ich sage etwas war vor einer anderen
sache dann bedeutet das eigentlich es
war danach alles war zeitlich zeitstrahl
weiter links wenn es davor war aber er
meint jetzt wohl davor mit ihr in dem
sind also die zukunft war dass es weiter
nach rechts gelingt waren so verstehe
ich das nicht
das was herr nach geschehen war und ich
findet ihr jetzt diese stelle ist wirkt
ein bisschen schwierig so dass schelling
sich hier von der bloßen betrachtung der
b3 also früher oder später als endlich
was war davor was wir danach abgrenzen
möchte das ist für schelling nicht das
richtige verständnis von zeit und er
spricht hier von einer eigentlichen
vergangenheit von einer eigentlichen
zukunft aber sie ich gebe das gerne ins
plenum wie sehen sie
sicherlich die freiheits thematik hängt
immer mit zusammen
das haben wir ja schon dadurch gesehen
dass schelling davon sprach dass man
sich zu sich selbst verhalten muss ein
selbst verhältnis entwickeln muss und
dass wir die zukunft gestalten müssen
dass wir uns ziele setzen und seine
theologie haben das ist alles im kontext
dieser freiheits thematik wir können
natürlich jetzt nicht in einer sitzung
ist eine ganze freiheits theorie wir uns
erarbeiten aber die klingt jedenfalls
immer mit an wir sehen ein solches
zeitverständnis design aktives ein
qualitatives ein organisches
zeitverständnis also das hier ist
sozusagen die standards sehen sie hier
standard die beere ist die standard
standard und schelling möchte eine neue
zeit betrachtung haben die nicht eine
standard theorie ist dass er möchte so
eine revolutionäre theorie haben die
eben diese nicht nur nach vorher nachher
relationen das ganze betrachtet das ist
die beere zu lese ich jetzt dieses zitat
hier
es ist ein bisschen gewagt also was auf
die frage was ist das geschehen ist das
was herr nach geschehen ist ja das war
es ja nach denk mir jetzt erstmal was
danach also was später geschehen ist das
heißt ihr was was zukünftig ist wenn ich
nicht ganz schlau geworden und die was
ist das geschehen wird das was sie davor
geschehen ist das was davor geschehen
ist ist aber doch eigentlich die
vergangenheit das ist ja gerade die
antwort auf die frage was ist was
geschehen ist das was davor geschehen
ist deswegen war jetzt ein bisschen
irritiert ich interpretiere ist aber so
dass das was davor war einfach ihrem
zeit schreibt weiter rechts lag und das
was er nachher weiter zurück lag
das ist dass die auffassung der bereich
der zeit und die möchte schelling eben
die standardtheorie die möchte schelling
hier kritisieren das sind bloß
mechanische zeit hier spielt us freiheit
keine rolle
hier gibt es bloß quantitäten und keine
qualitäten
das kann man glaube ich jemanden
zusammen
fassen wir und davon möchte eben eine
eigentliche zukunft und eine eigentliche
vergangenheit abgrenzen so würde nämlich
daraus folgt nach dieser standard sich
das in der welt dass die welt in sich
keine vergangenheiten keine zukunft habe
dass alles was mir von anfang geschehen
ist und was bis zum ende geschehen wird
nur zu einer großen zeit gehört versteht
es das also praktisch nur die b3 gilt
das ist das ist glaube ich so kann man's
rekonstruieren also wenn wir eben nur
nach vorher nachher fragen so würde
daraus folgen dass es keine
vergangenheiten keine zukunft gibt weil
natürlich in jedem moment hier weil hier
eben sagen diese vergangenheit gar keine
rolle spielt und weil hier wird nicht
unterschieden zwischen vergangenheit und
zukunft in der bh hier geht es einfach
nur um das vorher nachher hier wird die
ganze zeit betrachtet in ihrer ganzen
ausziehen und nicht in ihrer dynamik in
ihrer bewegung
hier wird einfach ein zeitstrahl
ausgebreitet und dadurch eben immer
vorher nachher entschieden
genau
völlig richtig hier könnte es auf jede
beliebige zeit beliebig verschieben wie
sie sagen genau und zwar deswegen können
wir das beliebig verschieben weil wir
hier kein subjekt haben was uns einen
festen fixpunkt gibt das heißt ich muss
hier noch subjekt eintragen er also
bitte hier
und es ist objekt los subjekt los dass
auch noch ein wichtiger punkt also
praktisch ich mache sie noch mal hin a3
ist organisch freiheitlich qualitativ
das organisch meint auch theologisch und
hier auch noch super ex objektbezogen na
und die bücherei dagegen ist eben
mechanisch ich sag mal so mechanisch und
frei
quantitativ und der objektiv praktisch
oder nicht nicht zurückgezogen
ja gab es noch eine meldung habe ich
noch jemand übersehen
menschen die welt an sich als subjekt
hin und gibt es um die zeit der welt die
da ist mir gar keine zeiten vor der welt
bist du das gewünschte seite so einfluss
diese brücke leben die gegenposition 15
und 1
ich weiß eben nur nicht ob er als die
welt alter so heißt ja jetzt diese
schrift mir scheint dass er die welt
alter in diarra ersetzt also dass eben
die zeit diese stufen hat gewisse ja
gewisse dimensionen hat das scheint mir
ihren punkt der a3 zu sein also dieses
ganze projekt die welt alters erhalt zu
diese schrift die ist in meinen augen
auf die a3 bezogen
[Musik]
es ist glaube ich auch nur also das ist
das ist alles geschichte eine geschichte
ist das kabel jetzt auch noch vergessen
hier das wichtigste ist natürlich dass
geschichte geschichten und da schreibe
ich immerhin zeit in einem versteck hat
sich in klammer sandkuhl modell sanduhr
modell so kann man sie es vielleicht
etwas veranstalten
alles was uns umgibt weiß dann eine
unglaublich hohe vergangenheit zurück
die ältesten bildung der erde tragen ein
so fremdes ansehen dass wir uns von der
zeit ihres entstehens und der damals
wirkenden kräfte kaum einen begriff zu
machen im stande sind
den größten teil derselben finden wie in
trümmer zeugen einer wilden verwüstung
seien gestürzt
ruhigere zeiten folgten aber auch sie
durch stürme unterbrochen und samt ihren
schöpfungen unter den einer neuen
begraben
in einer unbedenklichen reihe von zeit
hat je die folgende die vorhergehende
zugedeckt so dass sie kaum etwas
ursprüngliches nach zeit eine menge von
schichten die arbeit von jahrtausenden
muss hinweg genommen werden um endlich
auf den grund zu kommen
also hier wird jetzt zeit als etwas
schicht mäßiges verstanden schichten und
da haben natürlich auch die archäologie
sie kennen alle von foucault nach
geologie die server kennen sie nicht
also die archäologie des wissens hier
geht es eben auch darum dass sich der
historiker oder der philosoph als und
die philosophin als eine sagen
archäologen versteht die die
verschiedenen schichten derzeit das ist
dann wieder das qualitative
zeitverständnis
ihrem hier aufdeckt aber wir haben eben
immer so muss mir das vorstellen wenn
das die vergangenheit ist hier das ist
sein kein horizontales modell dessen
vertikales modell der zeit also dass die
vergangenheit nicht links legt das wäre
das horizontale modell vergangenheit ist
das linke so denkt dass die celli mich
sondern stellen denkt das ganze
gestaffelt gestuft also und das würde
jetzt wieder zu dieser steigerung passen
wo sie gesagt hatten treppenstufen also
dass man sagt hier die wenn wir stufen
haben und wenn die vergangenen die
gegenwart die oberste stufe ist von
treppen und es ist klar dass darunter
die vergangenheit eben die treppenstufen
sind die unter uns liegen
wir stehen auf diesen dritten stufen
letztendlich also kann man sagen das ist
die vergangenheit
das ist jetzt ein vertikales
zeitverständnis also in jedem gegenwarts
punkt stehen wir auf einem sozusagen
archäologischen fällt was wenn wir etwas
mehr tiefe graben uns ganz interessante
dinge zum vorschein bringen lässt
schichten also wir stehen auf
verschiedene schichtungen hier die
vergangenheit etwas unter uns ist und
nichts war es jenseits oder links von
uns ist wie in diesem beispiel hier ist
eine ganz interessante zeit auffassung
ist eine gestufte theorie eine kleine
sei ein vertikales modell im gegensatz
zum horizontal modell
natürlich muss man jetzt hier wieder
kritisch anmerken dass hier auch wieder
eine räumliche derzeit stattfinden das
ist etwas was heiliger dann später immer
wieder kritisiert dass wir uns zeitlich
es eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen
können
er ist zu verheimlichen das ist ja eine
ganz klare verheimlichung und auch
dessen zeitstrahl ist eine ganz klare
freue mich und das sollten wir uns immer
bewusst sein dass da natürlich was von
der zeit verloren geht wenn wir es so
darstellen das ist auch noch richtig
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich mal hier ein bisschen
was über springen moment gibt es hier
noch was
[Musik]
das leben sie vielleicht noch vor wenn
die vor uns liegende welt durch so viele
mittel zeiten herab gekommen endlich
diese geworden ist wie ver möchten wir
auch nur das gegenwärtige zu erkennen
ohne wissenschaft des vergangen schon
die eigenheiten einer ausgezeichneten
menschlichen individualität sind uns oft
unbegreiflich bevor wir die besonderen
umstände erfahren unter denen sie
geworden ist und sich gebildet hat und
der natur sollte man so leicht auf ihre
gründe kommen ein hohes werk des
altertums steht als ein umfassendes
ganzes vor uns bis wir derart seines
wachstums und seiner allmächtigen
ausbildung auf die spur gekommen
wie viel mehr muss dies bei einem so
vielfach zusammengesetzten individuum
als schon die erde ist der fall sein
welche ganz andere verwicklungen und
verschränkungen müssen hier stattfinden
auch das kleinste bis zum sandkorn herab
muss bestimmungen an sich tragen
hinter die es unmöglich ist zu kommen
ohne im ganzen lauf der schaffende natur
bis zu ihm zurück gelegt zu haben
alles ist nur werk derzeit und nur durch
die zeit erhält jedes ding seine
eigentümlichkeit und bedeutung
also sandkorn hinab das ist natürlich
ein interessanter bezug zur sanduhr die
hierhin gemalt habe das sind das land
also dieser letzte satz alles ist nur
werk der zeit und durch die durch die
zeit erhält jedes ding seiner
eigentümlichkeit oder wie verstehen sie
das diesen satz also hier wird jetzt
sozusagen die zeit als subjekt gedacht
also nicht nur subjektiv insofern wir
sie existenziell gestalten in freiheit
sind die zeit selbst wird zum subjekt
gemacht also gerade nicht mehr nur
objekt die zeit die ist ein objekt die
betrachten wir die zeit selbst die tut
etwas sie erhält sie sie wirkt wie
verstehen sie denn das ja genau und zum
beispiel mensch mensch ist nur als
geschichtlicher mensch in seiner
entwicklung
seine lebensgeschichte ist seine
persönlichkeit seine individualität
kommt nur dadurch zustande dass er unter
bestimmten geschichtlichen sozialen
kontexten eben herangewachsen ist
die zeit formt ihre individuen so reden
wir ja heutzutage noch jede zeit hat
ihre bringt ihre subjekte hervor
in den 70er 80er gab es eben mehr solche
individuen rates mode in 2010 gab es
eben mehr das was mode war
sagt das also etwas neues
wer dann keine bedeutung den
eigentümlichkeiten neues haus man kann
auch dann wollen wir uns nicht in der
lebenszeit von dem objekt aber wie das
zustande kommt es bald etwas in die zeit
tritt wird es nach diesem verständnis
von derzeit geformt oder letztendlich zu
seiner diversität gebracht genau
wenn ebenso bald was in die zeit tritt
wie ein neugeborenes kind wird es eben
durch die zeitlichen umstände durch die
zeitige organisch und subjektiv
verstehen wird geprägt so verstehe ich
sie entfallen sobald etwas in die zeit
fällt sobald etwas in diesem zeitlichen
rahmen überhaupt eintritt woher es kommt
ist natürlich die frage aber sobald das
eintritten zeit im rahmen wirkt die zeit
in ihm macht sich die zeit an ihm
bemerkbar
es wird sich entwickeln es wird und dann
sagt das ist ein werk derzeit sehr gut
ich meine ich meine sätze trans zentrale
rede so könnte man es lesen also zeit
ist die bedingung der möglichkeit dafür
dass überhaupt etwas seiner
eigentümlichkeit das ist nicht standard
also gerade nicht standard sei nicht
seine standard eigentlich kein seinen
eigentümlichkeit und bedeutung also
trans die zahl bedingungen der
möglichkeit ohne die zeit gebe es keine
eigenständigkeit
das ist tatsächlich weitere frage ich
mein so könnte man sitzt ja so könnte
man es jetzt lesen dass da ist ein
großer plan dahinter ist das würde
jedenfalls jetzt mit diesem organischen
modell zusammenpassen
aber es würde nicht zusammenpassen mit
unserer vorstellung von individueller
freiheit wenn wenn ich jetzt hier an dem
gibt es einen großen masterplan der wo
bleibt dann meine individuelle freiheit
bin ich ja nur marionette oder
determination verstehen sie das das
problem ist das wäre dann ihr hier
dieses standard modell der baureihe
dieses mechanische modell das wäre dann
ihr dieses modell so ein bisschen das
ein bisschen das problem aber
bestimmtheit heißt jetzt nicht dass es
der terminiert sein muss im schlechten
sinn
ich meine es gibt jetzt hier stellen wo
schelling auch von notwendigkeit spricht
die gibt es ja auch und das liegt schon
so was wie so ein masterplan aber
bestimmtheit heißt erstmal nur dass
irgendjemand eben seine bestimmtheit
seine individualität erhält durch die
zeit das heißt nicht dass er dadurch
vorherbestimmt ist
schauen sie sie haben die möglichkeit
sich selbst zu entwickeln indem sie in
der zeit sich bestimmen lassen indem sie
zum beispiel bestimmte dinge tun oder
sich bestimmten situationen aussetzen
aber sie sind es die sich bestimmen sich
selbst bestimmt die die sich
selbstbestimmt einer bestimmung
aussetzen das nicht so dass sie dann nur
alles auf sie einprasselt sondern sie
setzen sich ziele und die bestimmen sich
selbst aber sie können natürlich nur zu
einem individuum werden wenn sie
faktoren an sich ansetzen lassen das ist
klar dass überhaupt bestimmungen möglich
ist zb selbst bestimmen muss bestimmung
an sich tragen dass die bestimmung kann
das selbst form von selbstbestimmung st
das muss nicht fremdbestimmt fahren muss
der terminiert sein aber der kombination
ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit mit
masterplan oder unfreiheit
aber es gibt stellen wo er von der
notwendigkeit spricht und da wird es
dann schwierig gebe ich ihm recht da
gibt es später noch ein paar stellen wo
von seiner notwendigkeit ausgeht die
jetzt nicht so eine höhere notwendigkeit
ist jetzt nicht mit dieser mechanischen
bär ein notwendigkeit zusammenhängt
ja sehr gut genau sehr gut genau ganz
genau als es genau es ist eine formung
genau wir werden in der zeit geformt die
zeit formt uns natürlich auch zum
beispiel die geschichte wenn man jetzt
hier noch im wenn man jetzt zum beispiel
die nachkriegszeit erlebt hat oder eben
nicht das ist eben für uns als
individuum prägend prägen wäre zum
beispiel auch noch ein guter punkt die
zeit prägt uns sich jede sie stempelt
uns in einer gewissen weise aber sie
stempelt uns nicht ab sondern sie
ermöglicht uns in diesem bestimmten
rahmen auch eine bestimmte
individualität zu halten aber es ist
eben der große rahmen in dem etwas
stattfinden kann
wenn etwas was bedeutet es wenn
zeit also die klärung entstehen also
dann wäre das werk derzeit an sich
aufwärtspotenzial und würdig und welche
bedingungen brauchen unterlegt
genau also wir dürfen uns natürlich
nicht die zeit jetzt als und akteur
vorstellen da ist jetzt die zeit um die
zeit tot jetzt was das legt das jetzt
ein bisschen nach
also ich glaube dass hier genau also ich
glaube immer muss er sich so verstellt
zeit ist die bedingung der möglichkeit
von entwicklung von bestimmtheit also
zahlen wie bekannt ist trans
zentralmacht nur kann macht es eben
trans zentral im sinne der 3 so könnte
man vielleicht anders sagen möchte also
kannte hat eine transzendentale theorie
derzeit als reine anfangs form die aber
der b3 entspricht
und ich könnte ich lese in schellings so
dass er auch eine transzendente theorie
derzeit hat die aber der ara entspricht
also dass eben die subjektivität stärker
mit mit der ara in verbindung gesetzt
wird und die dadurch bekommt die zeit
noch eine stärkere qualität und
eigenmächtigkeit als es mit der bloßen
bieri der fall ist also wir dürfen uns
sicherlich
ja das ist eine gute frage also ich
verstehe es eben so dass eben alles was
ist nur deswegen sein kann weil es in
der zeit existieren also trans zentral
also ich lese ein bisschen schwächer
also ohne die zeit als bedingung der
möglichkeit oder die zeit gibt es keine
eigentümlichkeit gar keine
individualität und keine bedeutung
und das muss die zeit muss existieren
oder sie muss vorhanden sein sie muss
als rahmen da sein und uns ermöglichen
uns frei zu bestimmen
ich lese als ein bisschen schlechter ja
aber indem ich sage die bedingung der
möglichkeit bekomme ich schon ein
bisschen entgegen sagt da bekommt die
zeit seine gewisse mächtigkeit und boden
zum beispiel so ein bühnenboden auf dem
überhaupt erst auftreten können genau
ich lese jetzt ein bisschen er kann
tisch das problem ist die zeit jetzt
hier so die zeit ist kein subjekt die da
was tut und zone genau wie wir sind
natürlich werk unserer selbst aber nur
durch die zeit und ohne die zeit könnten
wir es nicht tun und deswegen lese ich
das jetzt ein bisschen ihr pikantes tod
sind die der transzendentalen mit dem
die möglichkeit aber eben nicht jetzt
auf der ebene der dieser bereich des
kantons und der aare also in
wirklichkeit
jetzt möchte ich mal hier so ein
bisschen
es kommt darauf an nur wesen zu sprechen
hier noch mal ganz kurz ich habe gesagt
die gedanken welche sich mehr über das
organische der zeit und der drei großen
abmessungen derselben die wir als
vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
unterscheiden durch oft wiederholte
betrachtung gebildet haben schriftlich
aufzuzeichnen
doch nicht ein streng wissenschaftlicher
nur in leicht mitteilender form damit
sie die unvollständigkeit ihrer
ausbildung selbst anzuerkennen scheine
welche ihren obgleich lang unter umher
getragenen
nach allen seiten zu geben der drang
derzeit nicht erlaubt hat also hier ist
jetzt wichtig dass er von einer
organischen verfasstheit der zeit
spricht das organische derzeit drei
großen abmessungen das sind natürlich
die dimensionen die abmessung ist die
deutsche übersetzung von die menschen
und unterscheidet er sie nicht
wissenschaft im strengen sinne nur in
einer bestimmten form
ja es ist also eine begründung dass auch
noch wichtig es ist leicht zu sagen und
jetzt allgemein angenommene meinung dass
die zeit nichts wirklich nichts von
unserer forschungs weise unabhängiges
ist unabhängig müssten wir natürlich
groß schreiben nach der heutigen
rechtschreibung
auch hat sie durch falsche vorstellungen
in den begriff der sie ebenso viel
scheinbares zum teil unwahres
eingeschlichen hat sich das es
verzeihlich scheint sie als ein bloßes
getriebe unserer gedanken anzusehen dass
aufhörte wenn wir nicht mehr lage wenn
wir nicht mehr tage zählten und stunden
und doch erfährt jedem eigentum
entlassen und widerspreche ich die
wesentlichkeit derzeit und diejenigen
selbst welche ihre nichtigkeit behaupten
weil sie zu lauten klagen über ihre
furchtbare wirklichkeit zu zwingen das
jetzt auch ein ganz zentrales zitat das
ist jetzt in meiner lesart gegen eine
kantige position gegen eine verbesserte
popularisiert kann tische version
derzeit gerichtet zeiterfassung
gerichtet können sie mal versuchen diese
kritik die in diesem zitat enthalten ist
noch einmal zu reformieren was
kritisiert jetzt cellini
[Musik]
als erst mal die meinung dass die zeit
nichts wirklich es sei nicht möglich ist
und nur etwas was von unserer
vorstellung abhängt also dass die zeit
oder das bloß subjektives im schlechten
sinn etwas bloß relatives und die sei
ein bloßes getriebe unserer gedanken
dass aufhörte wenn wir nicht mehr tage
gezählt und stunden ist doch interessant
das sagt natürlich kann nicht mehr
ja wobei natürlich newton sagen würde
die zeit verrinnt natürlich auch weiter
wenn wir aufhören zu zählen
es gibt die absolute zeit die immer
schon hintergrund markiert also newton
würde jetzt ja nicht sagen dass die zeit
nur subjektiv ist aber ich würde mal
sagen er wendet sich gegen eine
problematische kant leser kann sagt
natürlich dass die zeit etwas ist was
unsere subjektivität anhaftet und jede
frage ist insofern wieder da daran habe
ich jetzt gerade ihre frage ja was wäre
denn wenn es kein subjekt mehr ist das
nicht ein subjekt mir was der unbedingt
zählt
nicht was zählt aber was eben nicht mehr
isst lebt dann noch zeigen dann müsste
kann ehrlicherweise sagen nein wenn es
keine objekte gibt oder keine subjekte
geben kann prinzipiell an universo dann
müsste nach cannes folgen dass es keine
zeit gibt eine sitzung bis zu ende
gedacht wäre dass die folge und was
führt jetzt hier also schelling dagegen
ins feld er sagt es gibt nicht nur eine
es gibt nicht die subjektive zur
aktivität der zeit sondern ist die
wesentlichkeit derzeit das ist das
entscheidet die wesentlichkeit seien
also nicht die objektivität derzeit
nicht die subjektivität sank die
wesentlichkeit jetzt in diesem wesen da
und diesem sein und so weiter da klingt
natürlich auch schon heiliger an dieses
wesen schliche und dann sagte sie kann
eine furchtbare wirklichkeit darstellen
die wir anerkennen müssen all diesen
leuten würde er dann einfach sagen die
jetzt die zeit bestreiten würde sagen ja
aber in bestimmten situationen müsst ihr
sehr unter derzeit leiden zum beispiel
wenn du wieder ein krieg kommt oder eine
katastrophen zeit ein kriegszeit ja da
merkt immer wieder dass er in der zeit
zeit und ihre furchtbare wirklichkeit
bemerken ist so interpretiert ist ja
ja bestimmt auch wenn man krank ist wird
es so oder hier genau richtig
dann merken bestimmten existenziellen
situationen dass die zeit wesentlich ist
ganz wichtig das ist damit könnte man
sagen schellings ganze theorie
überschreiben die wesentlichkeit derzeit
aber erkannt einfach die transzendentale
tät derzeit oder meinetwegen die
subjektive zeit jetzt in jedem sinne
diese darstellung ihren hat als ihr
nochmal seine polemik gegen eine
verflachen kant interpretation wäre
schon längst verdienst lich gewesen form
und wesen schein und möglichkeiten
unsere vorstellung von derzeit zu
trennen wenn es noch die zeit wäre die
großen gegenstände einzeln oder getrennt
nach kapitel ab zu haben
erwünschter ist alles gleichen leben und
tat zu sehen wir ahnten 1 in der zeit
tief verborgen liegen und bis ins
kleinste ihnen organismus wir sind
überzeugt oder wer ist es nicht dass
jedem großen ereignis jeder folgen
vollen tat ihr tag ihre stunde
augenblick bestimmt ist jetzt kommt das
problem der determination endspiel und
dass sie kein nur früher ans tageslicht
tritt als die kraft will welche die
zeiten anhält und mäßig wäre es freilich
zu viel gewagt die tiefen der zeit schon
durchschauen zu wollen so ist doch der
augenblick gekommen das gros system der
zeiten in seine weitesten umfange zu
entwickeln also hier gebe ich jetzt der
auffassung recht das hier so eine
deterministische moment ins spiel kommt
wenn er eben sagt alles was ist das nach
dieser organist tischen vorstellung ist
in diesen organismus eben im verborgen
und auch in ihm angelegt es ist der
augenblick bestimmt hier augenblick
gestimmt dass sie nicht eine sekunde nur
früher eintritt konnte als die kraft
will welches die zeiten anhält und mäßig
also hier
liegt tatsächlich so eine art masterplan
modell so ein bisschen im hintergrund
das habe ich ja gesagt dass da noch so
eine stelle kommt aber das können wir
jetzt auch vielleicht ein bisschen
anders noch versuchen zu interpretieren
also natürlich wenn er seinen organismus
als vorstellungs modell hat dann ist das
so dass alles ineinandergreift dann hat
alles genau sein rechten platz genau
also dieses wesen das könnte so gut sein
dass das ist diese dimension möchte
jetzt allerdings ein bisschen rausnehmen
da kommt noch eine ganz starke
theologische dimension ins spiel
dann läuft das ganze letztendlich hinaus
auf die frage von göttlichen vorher
wissen und freiheit und menschlicher
freiheit und auch hier gibt es eine
riesen tradition gehen schon mit
augustinus vielleicht sogar noch vor
früher davor bei augustinus und
augustinus sagt das obwohl gott alles
vorher war es wieder noch frei sein
können
also es ist nicht so dass gottes vorher
wissen vielleicht auch vorher wollen
dass das mit unserer unfreiheit dass es
unsere unfreiheit bedingt das ist nicht
damit gesagt dass nur so nebenbei
bemerkt also es gibt eine riesen debatte
und er ist durchaus denkbar gottes
vorher wissen mit unserer freiheit zu
kompatibel anzusehen das ist möglich das
wird jetzt zwei wir wollen jetzt diese
frage nach der freiheit und
kompatibilität jetzt nicht weiter
verfolgen aber ich will einfach nur
sagen hier gibt es und gewissen
problematischen punkt der sowieso ein
masterplan darzulegen scheint
weil er ebenso eine organische zeit
auffassung hat und da kommt mir ganz
stark theologische dimension ins spiel
und jetzt kann sagte es wollen es die
zeit ist also auf gespannt wer die zeit
auch nur nimmt wie sie sich darstellt
fühlt in ihr einen widerstreit zweier
prinzipien eines das vorwärts strebt zur
entwicklung treibt und eines anhaltenden
der entwicklung widerstrebenden leistet
dieses andere als hemmende nicht
widerstand so wäre keine zeit weil die
entwicklung im nur ohne absatz und folge
geschehen würde aber noch nicht dieses
andere beständig von dem ersten befunden
also von dem was nach vorne strebt sowie
absolute ruhe tod stillstand und darum
wieder keine zeit denken uns nun aber
beide prinzipien in einem und demselben
wesen gleich wirken zu haben wir
zugleich den widerspruch fertig also
fertig wahrscheinlich überwunden
also hier wieder zwei prinzipien so ein
ruhendes oder ein hemmendes und ein
streben des nur in der koordination
dieser zwei tendenzen kommen überhaupt
eine entwicklung zu standen also dieses
streben dem moment wenn nur dieses
streben im moment wäre so wäre eben
alles so fortentwickelt
also man kann das sicherlich mit mit
gottes planen sich überlegen also wenn
eben nur dieser masterplan wären nur
dieser masterplan werden wenn nur der
masterplan existieren würde und nicht
existieren würde was sich ihm entgegen
setzt dann wäre der masterplan sofort
wirklichkeit
wir haben die master plan gottes
masterplan wenn da nichts hinterließ ist
sagt mit einem fingerschnipsen auf einen
streich mit anschlag haben wir den
ganzen masterplan für wirklich ist doch
klar
das stellt sich den masterplan nichts im
weg also wird er verwirklicht und jetzt
kommt aber hier ebenso was hemmendes ins
spiel und das ist das andere prinzip was
eben dafür sorgt soll direkt das obwohl
es vielleicht planen gibt dass alles
sich trotz dieses planes eben erst
entwickeln muss in einzelnen schritten
zur tiefe und das spannend dann die
ganze zeit auf und das ist sowas
hemmendes und ich interpretiere das so
dass das eben die individuen sind die
freien individuen die in gottes
masterplan einbezogen werden müssen und
die aber auch eine gewisse
eigenständigkeit haben letztendlich wird
das ganze wieder zurück auf leibnitz auf
diese leibnitz theorie der individuen
also sagen die freien individuen sind
hemmungslos masterplan gottes masterplan
kann sie nicht auf einen schlag
verwirklichen sondern er muss sich unter
einbezug dieser hemmung spot der
individuen hier ist entwickeln und
dadurch kommt die zeit ins spiel so
interpretiere ich jetzt das
wo wir von zeit reden die zeit ist schon
sehr weit fortgeschritten und zwar sind
wir jetzt kurz vor dem ende der heutigen
sitzung sie sehen eine unglaublich
reiche philosophie der zeit die uns
stellen gebietet schelling denkt hier
die ganze tradition zusammen auch wenn
sie den anfang dieser schrift lesen
haben das ist ein augustinus zitat da
kommt ein augustinus zitat wie mir
scheint wenn vor
hier wird sehr viel mit kants theorie
gemacht wir können sehr gut wie ich
glaube die standardtheorie der b34
identifizieren mit der a3 im verhältnis
setzen wir können wie gesagt die kantige
theorie hier noch mal wieder erkennen
und schellings modifikationen dieses
verständnisses komplett theologische
dimension noch ins spiel und vor allem
hier kommt eine existenz philosophische
dimension spiel und der wichtigste punkt
scheint mir hier die wesentlichkeit
derzeit das seien sie finden jetzt die
ganzen folien auf philo cast ich schicke
ihnen die anderen warum wenn wir hier
nochmal kurz durchklicken schauen sie
wir waren jetzt hier also aufs folie 18
hier und jetzt gehen weiter wir haben
noch 19 20
hier kommt man was interessantes der
prozessqualität
und dann die these dass jede mögliche
einzelne zeit die ganze zeit sei also
sagt in jedem zeitpunkt ist die ganze
zeit schon enthalten auch eine spannende
these die wir noch hier erklären wollen
dass das ist wiederum ganz entgegen
diesem vertikal diesem horizontalen zeit
modell schelling denkt das ganze eben im
sinne des vertikalen modells wie ich
sagte hier diese schichtungen dadurch
wird das ganze verständlich und wir
haben dann insgesamt 28 holen also zehn
folien haben wir noch einen nächsten
sitzung zu diskutieren bevor wir dann
mit mini alles toll stauffenberg so
reingehen werden glaube ich dann kann
man nämlich auf die phänomenologie und
dann kommen wir im neuen jahr auch auf
heiliger zu sprechen dann wünsche ich
ihnen jetzt noch einen schönen rest der
woche und falls man sich nicht mehr
sieht einen vor weihnachten und einen
guten rutsch ins neue jahr